hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
welcome to the top five features of
android 4.2 jelly bean so yes Android
4.2 is still jelly bean just like
Android 4.1 was it's just a minor point
one update but in this point one update
you do get at least five if not more
major feature updates that are at least
noteworthy so I'm gonna be going through
the top five today go ahead and leave
your number one down below the like
button on this video if you have a
number one already but uh yeah you'll be
able to get this update on the Nexus 4
right out the box on the Nexus 10 tablet
right out the box and it should be
rolling out over the air to the Galaxy
Nexus and the lucky Nexus 7 tablet and
of course a couple other devices later
in the future so keep your eye on the
news to find out if your device will get
it but without any further ado let's go
ahead and take a look at this countdown
number five is the new lockscreen in
Android 4.2 and I put new in quotes
because it's a very minor update but
it's an update so in the new lock screen
it's kind of cool because you can swipe
the entire lockscreen to the side to get
to the camera and take pictures and
video from there or you can swipe the
entire lockscreen to the other side and
visit your widgets and this is where
you'll be able to get information before
even unlocking the phone looks kind of
cool you can add some clocks you can add
a calendar widget and probably some
third-party widgets support later down
the road but to be honest it feels a
little bit half-baked right now because
you can only add one widget per swipe so
you can have a calendar but then if you
want your clock you have to go another
widgets which will be on a new page so
you have to swipe again to get to the
next widget but honestly it looks pretty
cool I'll probably just have my calendar
on my next swipe from the lockscreen and
that's pretty cool you can add an
information there number four is guest
you're typing in the new keyboard now
they call it guest you're typing or
gesture typing apparently is how it
supposed to be said but basically if
you've heard of a swipe for Android
already it never arrived in the Play
Store but it allowed you to swipe from
letter to letter and then let go and the
word that you've swiped across the
screen would appear there Google has
done the exact same thing with some
enhancements in a stock Android keyboard
so you can swipe across the letters you
want to make a word and as you're
swiping it'll update the preview of the
word it thinks you're going to type and
when you let go that word will appear in
a text box so you can type really really
fast obviously with this new swiping
method rather than typing like a regular
hunt-and-peck style
I've actually used swipe a lot before
this so having it in a stock Android
keyboard is a big deal and I'll
definitely be using it a lot it's really
fast really cool feature and of course
it still looks good number three is
quick settings you probably saw us
coming already quick settings is
accessible in more than one way you can
access it by swiping down the
notification bar with one finger and
tapping the quick settings button or you
can swipe down with two fingers on a
tablet you can swipe down the left hand
side for regular notifications or swipe
down the right hand side for your quick
settings your quick settings gives you
access to all sorts of really neat
convenient features so for example if
you're on a tablet your multiple user
account support is there you have a and
unique 1% battery indicator so your
battery percentage is there you have
quick access to your brightness your GPS
your Bluetooth all your different
toggles are there and once you tap the
brightness so get a little slider so you
never have to enter the actual settings
of Android you can just enter your quick
settings right there and if you do want
to enter the actual settings of Android
there's also a button in quick settings
to get to the full settings so I think
this is really neat I've been talking
about this in my Super Nexus video I
mentioned that this was baked into some
other previous rungs for Android likes
an engine mod and a okp
but now it is in stock Android you don't
have to route or do anything fancy I
just hit the microphone you have to do
anything fancy to get the quick settings
now it is built into Android you don't
have to go crazy out of your way to get
it so that's a nice touch number two is
the little things and I actually said
this in my Android 4.1 video the little
things there are so many little things
in jellybean that just made it more
polished a more complete feeling user
experience and Android 4.2 also has some
new little things for example in Gmail
4.2 you can finally now pinch to zoom
rich HTML emails you can check out the
new Google now improvements which will
integrate with Gmail and pick up on you
know the weather in places you might be
traveling or your hotel room reservation
or a package you might be tracking also
new in Android 4.2 is something called
daydream which is basically a
screensaver for your phone which is I
don't know it's cool I wouldn't use it
because that seems like a battery killer
but if you have some cool pictures in
your gallery you can use it also varies
like I said multiple user account
support on tablets so you can have Angry
Birds on one account and some angry
Birds piggies on another account and
when you switch over to the Angry Birds
piggies
count you'll probably be on a different
level so it'll remember what level
you're on it's very very cool it does
use more storage though so make sure you
get a higher end tablet maybe a 16 or 32
gig Nexus tablet and you'll be able to
love user account support
there's also wireless display settings
and a whole bunch of other bug fixes and
performance increases project butter is
still there it's still buttery smooth as
usual so there are a ton of new things
that make Android 4.2 jelly bean just as
lovable as the first iteration and last
but not least finally the number one new
feature in Android 4.2 you probably saw
this coming already is the new camera
the new user interface the new features
everything about that new camera and
gallery the new user interface of the
camera is pretty simple you have a new
focus ring so it's green when your focus
red when you're not you can tap to focus
like usual and also you can access your
settings in a camera just by tapping in
the middle and swiping outwards to
whichever setting you want to adjust so
you can adjust your flash or your
exposure settings or your location
settings or even what white balance
you're using just by swiping over the
correct setting and it'll adjust it
automatically you can also change
storage location and image size moving
right on up to video mode you can still
take 1080p video if your phone supports
it at are still time lapse and then
moving up from that there is panorama
photos which lets you take panorama in
both horizontal and portrait mode so
whichever way you hold your phone you
can take panorama is that way and then
moving on up from that photosphere when
you turn photosphere on you'll be able
to line it up and basically stitch a
whole bunch of photos together in a 360
degree panorama to create a massive
submerse 'iv
30 40 mega pixels in size and full of
detail and once you share it you'll have
the ability to view it just like you're
standing in the same place that the
photo was taken you can share this
photosphere as a regular really really
wide image but that doesn't always look
so great on like Twitter and Facebook
where I've been sharing them so if you
share it on Google+ on the desktop site
there's actually a photos for your
viewer which allows you to look up and
down and around the image just like
Google Street View and also in the new
gallery you can do that as well so if
you have a new photo so you're on the
gallery you tap the photosphere button
and it'll just zoom you right in and you
can start taking a look at that new
image you took up-down left-right again
just like you're staying there at Google
Street View the new gallery also has
some interesting and good new features
like you can add these Instagram like
Effects if you're into that kind of
thing you can instantly crop or adjust
the rotation of images so there's some
quick image editing features in there
and that's definitely helpful if you
edit stuff on the fly but overall the
new gallery is also a lot faster I
noticed I was impressed with the
performance so the new camera and
gallery is awesome in Android 4.2 also
just a tip for people taking photo
spheres since I figured while I'm here
I'll show you guys a lot of people when
you're taking panoramas
it'll be okay to swing your phone around
like this and not really keep it in the
same spot while you're taking a photo
sphere you'll notice when you're looking
at a Google Maps photo sphere it's
literally as if you're standing with
your head in space and looking around on
a swivel so when you're taking a photo
sphere try to keep the camera lens or at
least the camera in the same place so
instead of looking up and down all crazy
like that which looks a little weird
anyway you can just keep the camera in
place and tilt it up and tilt it to the
side and pivot it around to capture the
whole photo sphere and once you're done
you'll notice that gets the stitching a
lot better you want to have as many
things crossed over or looking a little
bit weird so I'll try to share the
better panoramas and photo spheres that
I take on Google+ and then your future
so if you're ready for those go out and
give this video a +1 or thumbs up and if
you enjoy the whole video of course feel
free to subscribe because there will be
more or like it in the near future
either way feel free to leave your
number one feature I was in between the
camera and the new keyboard for being my
number one feature but I went with the
new camera because it has that wow
factor but I definitely love the new
keyboard as well either way thanks for
watching guys I really appreciate it and
I will talk to you guys
video
you